TO GET RID OF WHAT IS IN YOUR
BODY, THAT IS A WONDERFUL STORY.
WATCHING 60 MINUTES THINKING
THIS IS A SALUTE TO BUCKING THE
SYSTEM, THEY WANT TO ANSWER YOU.
MONDAY MORNING STARTED TO BLOW
BACK IN THEIR FACE BECAUSE THEY
WERE MISSING A THING CALLED
CONTACT AND TOOK YOU OUT OF
CONTEXT AND CAUSE A LOT OF
CONTROVERSY.
WEDNESDAY RUNNING FOR THE HELL
BUT NEVER APOLOGIZED TO 60
MINUTES BUT DID DO A VIEWER
RESPONSE TO YOUR SEGMENT.
HERE IS A LITTLE OF IT WITH THE
REPORTER, SHARON OUT FONZIE.
LISTEN.
>> IN THE MAIL THIS WEEK
COMMENTS IN HER STORY ABOUT
DISPARITY AND DISTRIBUTION OF
COVID 19 VACCINE IN PALM BEACH
COUNTY, FLORIDA.
VIEWERS FOCUSED ON AN EXCHANGE
WITH FLORIDA GOVERNOR RHONDA
SANTOS IN A PRESS CONFERENCE,
SOME VIEWERS INCLUDED A RETIRED
NEWS MAN, EDITING AND REPORTING.
THEN THERE WAS THIS.
WATCHED 60 MINUTES FOR DECADES
WHICH AFTER YOUR BIASED PIECE ON
GOVERNOR DESANTIS I WILL ONLY
WATCH IT ONE MORE TIME, JUST TO
SEE IF YOU BROADCAST THIS
MESSAGE.
>> IS THAT AN APOLOGY?
>> OF COURSE NOT.
THEY ISSUED A LOT OF
MEALYMOUTHED STATEMENTS SINCE
THE EPISODE AIRED.
THEY KNEW WHAT THEY WERE PUTTING
ON THE AIR WAS FALSE AND THAT IS
THE PROBLEM THEY HAVE, THEY
TALKED TO THE PEOPLE, REFUSED TO
PUT PEOPLE ON THE AIR WHO WERE
EXPLAINING WHAT HAPPENED, EDITED
THE EXPLANATION OUT, AND AND
THEY HAVE SO MUCH CONTEMPT FOR
VIEWERS, THEY ADMIT THAT IT IS
FALSE, THAT IS THE RESPONSIBLE
THING TO DO, THEY HAD A
POLITICAL MISSION TO SMEAR ME,
THEY THOUGHT THEY COULD DO IT,
DRIVE-BY TO THE NEXT TARGET BUT
I HAVE A PLATFORM, THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT BUT HOW MUCH
CONTEMPT DO THEY HAVE FOR THEIR
FELLOW AMERICANS.
BRIAN: WASN’T ONLY FALSE, IT
WASN’T EVEN FAIR.
PRESENTED AS IF SHE ASKED YOU A
QUESTION AND YOU NEVER ANSWERED,
TALKING BACK TO HER BUT YOU GAVE
HER A 2-MINUTE ANANSWER AND RATH
THAN ENCAPSULATE IT, YOU WENT
INTO GRANULAR FASHION AND
EXPLAINED THE WHOLE THING.
AND EDITED FOR CLARITY.
DIDN’T LIKE YOUR POINT OF VIEW.
>> EVERYTHING I SAID IS VERIFIED
BY EVERYBODY ELSE INVOLVED IN
THIS, THE DEMOCRATIC MAYOR OF
PALM BEACH COUNTY, EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT DIRECTOR WHO IS ALSO
A DEMOCRAT FROM SOUTH FLORIDA.
WHAT I SAID IS WHAT HAPPENED.
WHAT THEY SAID IS WHAT HAPPENED.
THE RESPONSIBLE THING WOULD BE
NOT EVEN TO AIR IT BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY YOU DON’T
OBVIOUSLY YOU DON’T HAVE A STORY
HERE BUT THEY WANTED TO DO THE
SMEAR SO THEY TOOK ALL THE
EVIDENCE, AND LEFT IT ON THE
CUTTING ROOM FLOOR AND CONTINUED
AND LAUNCHED A REALLY
IRRESPONSIBLE CHARGE SO THAT IS
WHAT YOU DON’T DO.
THEY ARE INTENTIONAL OR RECKLESS
OR TRYING TO DO THIS.
AINSLEY: YOU ARE DOING A GREAT